[Musique]
g
jean marc et diers bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv soixante dix
huit pour un vip qui vous est
entièrement consacré vous êtes ici en
tant que peintre en tant qu'auteur décès
et surtout vous faites partie des cinq
commissaires d'une exposition qui
démarre très bientôt le 15 février qui
va durer jusqu'au 14 avril qui a lieu à
l'espace richaud et qui est consacrée au
peintre philippe le jeune
voilà donc vous êtes ici pour nous en
dire le maximum
vous avez alors je dis que vous êtes
essayiste vous avez été été aussi
l'élève de philippe lejeune puisque vous
êtes aussi pas encore voilà arrêtez moi
si je me trompe l'oeil de dieu qui m'a
transmis cette volonté d'aller au fond
des choses et de l'est c'est justement
devant tout cas d' étudier la peinture
de panique non pas théorique
oui alors j'ai sous les yeux de son fils
aime le descendre à classer votre
restait sur de la croix c'est ça voilà
ça c'était il ya combien de temps
c'était il ya cinq ans sur une oeuvre
très peu connu qui se trouve en corse et
pour lequel il a eu une importance car
vous habitez à oka voit la fille du plus
jeune est celui qui m'a poussé en fait
tu as à faire cet essai est maintenant
une fois qu'il est mort oui il ya quatre
ans les circonstances font que je me
suis dit que sa peinture est et est à
situer dans l'histoire de l'art et qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait étudier donc là
dans ce succès un essai pour essayer de
trouver la place de philippe lejeune et
on y réfléchissant bien sa place
ben c'est l'héritage de delacroix ou
dans la seconde moitié du 20e siècle
lui-même au début de 2è millénaire
d'accord parce parfait parce qu'il a eue
maurice denis comme comme m comme
maurice denis a été l'un de ceux qui a
vraiment fait comprendre de la croix en
1930 lors de la grande rétrospective
ça commence à être
on commence à en parler d'accord parce
que l'hommage à cesana un peu occulté le
fameux tableau qui obligeait d'orsay 20
par denis son importance david delacroix
et c'est vrai que je ne parlais tout le
temps de de la croire à étampes
quand j'étais adolescent il a fondé
cette école de peinture l'école des
temps à l'atelier de la vigne ce qui
fait que on avait cet avantage énorme
c'est qu'on connaissait le journal de la
croix sans l'avoir lu n'est qu'à
tellement il en était imprégné
l'université tout le temps qu'il fera et
donc on avait déjà une exégèse
d'interprétation du journal avant de
l'avoir lu et en remontant de fil en
aiguille je me suis dit qu'au fond c'est
peut-être ce que lui avait déjà eu et
j'ai posé la question juste avant sa
mort 6 quel est exactement l'importance
de maurice denis et il a effectivement
reconnu
il m'a dit que même si son père en fait
qui lui avait dit de lire les services
de niche vous coupent avait un atelier
d'art sacré et à 16 17 ans fils du plus
jeune est entré dans cet atelier
tout à fait cet atelier est d'ailleurs
c'était pas tout à fait un hasard se
trouvait était juste à côté du dernier
atelier de la croix est tous ces
afficheurs steinberg à paris dakar oui
tout tout se tient et si bien est ce que
le camp lejeune fréquentent cet atelier
denis vient de créer le musée delacroix
en fait d'accord ok vous savez de
l'amour pour en parler des heures mais
il se trouve que là on va se concentrer
sur l'exposition philippe lejeune de la
prof 20e siècle voilà et alors philippe
lejeune 1924 2014 c'est la première fois
qu'il y a une véritable rétrospective
jeudi véritable parce que il ya 150
tableaux celui dont c'est énorme voilà
70 ans de peinture et quand on visite
l'exposition on démarre avec des
tableaux des petits portraits de ses
enfants des autoportraits et cetera de
jeunesse un peu oui on ne marque pas des
choses et à mesure à toute l'évolution
de son style et ses c'était le but et
c'est ça qui a été dit assez difficile
et c'est pour ça qu'on est à cinq dont
la une de ses filles
oui mais elle est commissaire de
l'exposition comme on disait tout à la
wii parce que tout un travail quand même
scientifique il a fallu faire date et
les tableaux ça l'air de rien mais tout
ça n'a jamais été fait banon et pour
pouvoir comprendre justement le
l'évolution mettre des dates à quel
moment
il a basculé à quel moment sa peinture
s'est transformée et là les dates sont
très importantes et tout ce travail
d'historien en fait est fait maintenant
d'accord alors là nous avons la fiche
comment se nomme ce tableau ce tableau
basse et le saint sébastien c'est une
version tout à fait actualisé n'oublions
pas que bernard buffet des pietà avec
des enfants
avec un cartable sur le dos années 50 tu
as fait dans le
dans ce goût là mais c'était aussi ce
que maurice denis faisait quand il
faisait des annonciation sur le paysage
en arrière fond c'est lui était moderne
et c'était celui de saint germain en
laye lequel c'était voilà oui c'était
mon idée ni typique en plus sur les
tailles de la fiche on voit pas
forcément que c'est un sébastien guigne
voilà donc c'est une version entièrement
réactualisé oui d'accord et je voudrais
juste faire un petit point sur ce qu'on
appelle l'art sacré finalement parce que
c'est comment on peut le définir vite
fait bah c'est donc le l'atelier qui a
suivi ça fait des années que les gènes
quoi c'est une question assez assez
complexe parce que soit on considère que
tout arrêt sacré qu'est la différence
entre la vie réelle de bach à la
naissance i way ensuite qu'un art
liturgique le grégorien et liturgique la
messancy beaucoup plus dures gicle école
que la chaconne en tout cas pas et la
dentellière de vermeer on peut aussi
considérer que c'est de l'art sacré en
revanche dans chaque pas de sacrées mais
que l'atout tard et ça crée une certaine
façon ensuite c'est un art religieux
alors elle reste que c'est ça qu'ils
pratiquent
alors il l'a pratiqué des décors
d'église et une église
il a fait des décors d'église d'ailleurs
des vitraux des vitraux mais aussi des
fresques ça s'était parallèlement à sa
carrière de peintre c'est par des
professeurs ces parallèles et ça permet
de comprendre sa peinture c'est à dire
que la pratique du vitrail par exemple
permet de comprendre notamment la façon
dont il va poser les glacis cette
transparence est un gruyère qui radient
du tableau en tableau est d'ailleurs les
genres le voit ici mais il ya des
pressions de vitrail
oui même dans le trait qui a c'est quand
même comment dire un peu irréel comme ça
d'une physique et dieu la lumière et
c'est ce travail de huy de vitrail il
l'a vraiment se ressent dans sa peinture
et sa peinture n'est pas un art d'église
au sens propre
d'autant que quand hilton sais pas ce
qui va peindre alors voilà donc attendez
on va revenir au probabiliste mme mais
si je voulais dire que chaque tableau a
tout de même un titre biblique
oui c'est d'inspiration biblique et je
dirais même plutôt d'inspiration
apocalyptique comme olivier messiaen
d'ailleurs pas plus loin du sacre et
olivier messiaen qu'est un compositeur
de musique sacrée aussi un compositeur
tout court d'accord il a composé
effectivement de musique sacrée et le
mais il est pas pris caravage aussi
d'ailleurs attendait parce qu'il a fait
un tableau un hommage
on va regarder défiler tous les tous les
tableaux qu'on va s'arrêter pour les
commenter la revoilà valls et judith
donc j'ai dit est en fête et holopherne
tableau car après deux sujets traités
par caravage entre autres pompiers de st
alors cette femme c'est c'était ce
geneviève dormann avec qui venait de se
marier
c'était au début de leur mariage ils
sont restés mariés cinq ans voilà trois
filles
j'ai pas exactement quand puisque je
suis pas sûr que ce tableau là était
dater précisément le mariage et sa tête
à lui un tableau près moynier toi parce
qu'elle le quitte au bout de cinq ans ça
je peux vous ressassez le côté people ah
oui c'est vrai que le rsa je connais
plus sa peinture que le peintre en
parler parce que moi je connais le
peintre à la fin ok mais ce qu'elle doit
continuer oui dites moi pardon mais c
est le en tout cas à ce moment là elle
ne s'est pas encore l'écrivain que tout
le monde connaît geneviève dormann
n'était pas la liste d'accord ok ensuite
on va regarder les autres tableaux et là
c'est un autoportrait donc été fait ce
qui agace est une île qui est près de
capri peuple il y est allé rencontrer un
peintre italien cremonini qui était
professeur aux beaux-arts de paris alors
que leonardo cremonini n'était pas
encore à ce moment là mais il le sera
dans les années 90 et après sur douala
mais à ce moment-là il le maire voulait
reconnu cremonini lui il faut que j'ai
pu connaître les deux cas donc ça c'est
un des dernier autoportrait
c'est l'autoportrait qui peint là bas
d'ailleurs on voit la lumière
méditerranéenne
oui c'est tout l'art de l'été et il
rejoint cremonini
avec jeudi norman a priori et
l'importance de cremonini c'est qu'il
retrouve chez cremonini quelque chose
qui ne voient pas de cette manière là
chez ses contemporains en fait de
l'effet de l'école de paris c'est la
peinture probabiliste alors voilà c'est
la jolie en finir merci leveaux qu'est
ce que c'est que la peinture
probabiliste dont nous parle quand on
visite cette exposition oui alors le
serbe quoi concrètement le 13 mai et de
lejeune d'ailleurs alors concrètement on
démarre est assez que quand leonard de
vinci devait prendre un apprenti
oui celui qui ne voyaient pas quelque
chose dans les nuages ou dans les tâches
sur un mur
il le prend pas d'accord parce que il ya
eu c'est organiser le tableau le tableau
en lui-même un pouvoir créateur 1
c'est en fait là une sorte de troisième
personne sur le tableau en train de
naître
il va falloir l'organiser et donc le
peintre ne peut pas savoir exactement ce
que va être son oeuvre avant et ça le
jeune il tenait beaucoup
est ce qu'il retrouve ses chromes unis
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'ils
considéraient que le peintre qui sait
déjà ce qu'il va faire au fond est plus
un fabricant qu'un quand on est d'accord
donc c'est parce que le pain doit se
laisser imprégner et part parce qu'ils
voient et terroristes de ce qui se passe
sur la toile sera une sorte
d'improvisation et ça ce qu'il a pu déjà
le découvrir avec jean soubervie
d'accord qui a rogné déjà bas qui a pris
la suite de maurice denis aux ateliers
d'art sacré après la mort tragique de de
nickel été renversée par un camion en 43
son second maître 7 et jean soulard vie
qui était un peintre cubiste
donc c'est lui a fait une ouverture sur
les avant gardes
disons plus plus contemporaine ce que
denis c'était l'art moderne une
génération quand même avant donc la
peinture probabiliste après bas et d'en
trouver l'arbre de trouver l'harmonie
c'est à dire que oui son verbe il autant
non mais son verbe il ne voyait pas non
plus ne savent pas ce qu'ils allaient
faire il a pas toute sa vie une fois
trois femmes sur une plage et le sujet
vient après c'est ce que disait oui
d'accord
bon bah qu il le dit c'est que c'est
vrai aussi je me demandais vous qui
l'avez côtoyé vite pour terminer il
était comment c'était quoi cette école
détente ça correspondait à à qu'elle y
avait une philosophie avait aubin
c'était la pratique du portrait on se
retrouve le sénégal un portrait autour
du portrait vt droit et comment il était
comme professeur très
très ouvert d'accord la bande dessinée
par exemple badigeon qui m'a pas
dissuadé
vous êtes pas dit cela on a laissé venir
à moi les petits enfants
après on va en avoir un second je vous
coupe parce que on commente en même
temps les tableaux celui-là c'est quoi
ça c'est l'hommage à mission c'est
l'hommage au fameux messiaen voilà donc
comme professeur ils étaient ouverts
d'esprit il est celle et les élèves
allaient où il était très rigoureux dans
le dans la pratique du portrait et ses
racines à une unité absolument sans
concession d'akasaka ligne oui ça il a
dit à peu près à tout le monde que vous
êtes la peinture ce que le bruit de la
musique oui au début oui oui bien sûr il
a aussi animé des ateliers à
fleury-mérogis en milieu carcéral
oui aussi l'arrivée des peintres à
étampes conditions dont vous la wii
l'article la pratique du portrait le
dimanche était très très formatrice et
c'est vrai qu'à cette période là je
fréquente et georges pichard
à du père elle la semaine et le week-end
et murray avec le jeune donc il a été
très important autant pour ses élèves
que en tant que peintre pour % public
l'a donc j'encourage tout le monde à les
voir cette magnifique exposition 70 ans
de peinture à l'espace richaud à
versailles
et c'est juste impressionnant de voir
l'évolution sur 70 à 150 tableaux voilà
un grand merci jean marc qui dira
c'était court il ya plein de choses à
dire mais c'est toujours pareil
voilà à bientôt merci
[Musique]